[Applaudissements]
bonjour tout le monde donc je suis
présidente et fondatrice
pour ceux qui connaissent Sea Shepherd
c'est une onde de défense de l'océan
extrêmement combative puisqu'on est
connu surtout pour des félins comme le
fait d'avoir couler et prenez des
baleiniers illégaux d'avoir mené 15 ans
de bataille navale en Antarctique entre
la chasse Balinière de l'industrie
baleine japonaise et d'avoir confisqué
des milliers de kilomètres de fila
illégaux donc en France on est surtout
connu pour notre rôle de lanceur
d'alerte sur les captures de dauphins
dans le golf de Gascogne donc on se rend
sur les zones de pêche pour documenter
les captures et alerter le grand public
sur sur une problématique qui qui était
jusqu'à le gâteau encore très méconnue
mais aujourd'hui en fait je vais surtout
vous parler
d'individus en fait nous à sea shepher
on a surtout l'habitude de sensibiliser
sur le rôle de l'océan sur l'importance
de l'océan des populations marines sur
le fait que si l'océan meurt nous
mourront parce que c'est le premier
organe de régulation du climat le
premier plus de carbone voilà et qu'il
n'y a pas de vie sur Terre qui soit
possible sans les océans
donc on travaille surtout sur la
conservation des populations mais mais
au cours de l'année dernière on a été
confronté à plusieurs cas qui porte sur
des individus des individus qui se sont
retrouvés en détresse qui se sont égarés
dans la scène qui sont venus échouer
vivants sur nos plages et la façon dont
ces affaires là ont été gérés a été
extrêmement pour nous un peu difficile
et en même temps très instructive sur
notre rapport et à l'océan et aux
individus marins
donc je vais commencer l'histoire par la
fin c'est à dire
ceci donc il y a quelques jours j'étais
en Angleterre avec une partie de mon
équipe on est parti se former au
sauvetage d'urgence de mammifères marins
en détresse donc on est avec vdmlr c'est
une association anglaise qui travaille
depuis 25 ans sur comment
intervenir de la meilleure des façons
éviter les erreurs et donner un maximum
de chances à ces individus que ce soit
des baleines des dauphins des phoques
qui s'échouent sur nos plages donc en
Angleterre c'est très intéressant parce
que ils ont alors ils sont équipés mais
en France on n'a pas ce genre de
matériel ça c'est des formations qui
dispensent au grand public nous on a le
droit à une formation beaucoup plus
poussée en tant que en tant qu' ONG donc
quels sont les gestes de survie à faire
quand on est face à un dauphin qui
s'échoue
la personne que vous voyez avec le gilet
rescue c'est un professionnel de du
désenchet des enchères autrement de
grandes baleines donc ils sont prises
dans les filets en pleine mer autant
vous dire que nous on n'a pas du tout
cette expertise en France et autant vous
dire que ça nous intéresse beaucoup de
l'acquérir
et voilà et ça c'est pareil c'est un
matériel qui permet d'augmenter les
chances de survie et de surtout de
stresser le moins possible l'animal et
de ne pas risquer de le blesser quand on
le remet à l'eau on a eu des images de
sympathisants qui nous ont envoyé par
exemple
des vidéos de en train de tirer un
dauphin par la queue pour le remettre à
l'eau donc parce qu'il pense bien faire
en fait c'est catastrophique on condamne
quasiment le dauphin en faisant ce genre
de choses donc ça c'est la petite photo
de groupe souvenirs
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'on a été en
Angleterre pour se former
ça a commencé
là
ça c'est vice on a baptisé lisse c'est
un Beluga qui s'est retrouvé dans la
Seine en août dernier comme vous pouvez
le voir sur les images il est
extrêmement maigre donc nous on est
contacté par la préfecture le jour où
lycée signalé dans la scène il est déjà
très avancé à peu près 60 km dans les
terres donc c'est très compliqué
ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on mobilise en
urgence une équipe avec un bateau on
suit lisse dans la Seine et on se pose
la question de savoir comment est-ce
qu'on va l'aider à regagner le large
il y a des écluses à passer en plus il a
passé une écluse on sait pas comment il
a fait il rentre de nouveau dans une
écluse et là on fait fermer les Cluses
on fait fermer l'écluse le but c'était
surtout de pouvoir avoir une chance en
fait de savoir ce qu'il a est-ce qu'il
est malade est-ce qu'on peut l'aider
est-ce qu'il est atteint d'un mal
incurable qui fait qu'il va souffrir
pendant des jours voir des semaines et
dans ce cas là est-ce qu'il faut pas
l'aider à partir c'est ce genre de
choses là qu'on voulait savoir et donc
on a bloqué l'écluse on est resté avec
lui à partir du moment où il était dans
l'écluse notre équipe s'est relayée 24
heures sur 24 à son chevet c'est à dire
qu'on notait le nombre de respirations
toutes les 5 minutes pour monitorer
l'état de stress parce que le but
c'était justement qui ne soit pas trop
stressé sinon on aurait ouvert l'écluse
avec aussi des problématiques que ça
pouvait engendrer parce que on était
très très loin de la mer avec un trafic
maritime intense savoir qu'on est dans
une eau vous en doutez extrêmement
pollué de l'eau douce très chaud on
était au mois d'août donc pas du tout
adapté à sa physiologie donc on est un
peu dans cette situation qui est pas du
tout idéal nous on est dans une course
contre la montre on se dit que plus il
passe de temps dans cette eau-là et plus
on n'est pas va se détériorer et en même
temps on n'a pas les moyens de le
déplacer de façon
rapide efficace et en minimisant le
stress pour lui et on a tout un panel de
d'expert je mets des guillemets parce
qu'en fait il y a pas beaucoup d'experts
qui s'y connaissent vraiment en béluga
en France qui donne qui donne leur avis
et notamment on a le réseau national
français qui est spécialisé dans les
échouages d'animaux morts qui qui
plaident pour deux choses soit de ne pas
intervenir soit de procéder à une
euthanasie
donc moi je me dis bon c'est un peu
hâtif quand même de décider d'une
euthanasie finalement cet animal il est
maigre mais est-ce qu'on sait vraiment
si son cas est désespéré et si il
souffre point qu'il faut qu'il faut le
mettre à mort donc je me dis on n'a pas
d'expert béluga dans ce groupe la
préfecture elle est la tant d'avoir des
conseils de personnes avisées puisque
elle-même n'a pas d'expertise dans la
matière donc je me dis bon bah je vais
contacter un des meilleurs experts
mondiaux de béluga Robert Michaud au
Québec je vais lui montrer les images
qu'on a fait avec celui-là puisque nous
on le filme sous l'eau on note son
comportement et on prend des vidéos et
des photos donc j'appelle Robert Michaud
au Québec je lui dis bon ben voilà on a
ce cas de béluga qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez il me dit envoie-moi tout ça et
je vais regarder en regardant les images
il me dit bon effectivement c'est un
animal qui est très bête mais c'est pas
un animal moribond les béluga ont quand
même une très forte résistance ça nous
arrivait par le passé de voir des
bélugas dans cet état d'amaigrissement
ce rétablir donc vu le comportement de
l'animal qui en plus tourné la tête et
tu es curieux de son environnement
il dit pour moi ça serait prématuré de
procéder à une euthanasie
donc je lui dis dans ce cas très bien
venez demain matin à La Réunion qu'on
fait avec la préfecture et et dites-leur
ça il y a aussi un autre point qui a été
avancé par par le réseau national des
choix c'est de dire qu'il fallait
surtout pas prendre le risque de perdre
le cadavre c'est à dire que si on
ramenait le béluga en mer et qu'il
allait mourir plus loin on perd des
cadavres et donc des informations qui
pourraient être utile à la préservation
de son espèce donc j'avance cet argument
aussi à Robert Michaud qui me dit bon
bah nous ça fait des décennies qu'on
autopsie les béluga je peux vous dire
que c'est pas ce Beluga là l'autopsie de
se belligala qui va qui va sauver
l'espèce
donc très bien il arrive le lendemain à
la Réunion il donne toutes ces
informations et du coup la préfecture
décide sur la base de son expertise de
ne pas procéder à une euthanasie et de
voir ce qu'on peut faire alors c'est là
que
les choses ce corps c'est que on se dit
bon l'idéal ça serait de pouvoir
monitorer son état de santé avoir des
vétérinaires qui viennent voir et le
problème c'est que on n'a pas les moyens
de transport on a pas de points de chute
c'est à dire que ils ne peuvent pas
rester plus longtemps que ça dans cette
dans cette eau douce très chaud donc il
faut absolument qu'ils se retrouvent
dans une eau salée la préfète qui pour
le coup était quelqu'un de très très
dynamique et qui avait envie de trouver
des solutions pour ce béluga arrive à
nous trouver une écluse à Ouistreham qui
donne sur la mer avec de l'eau salée
donc c'est mieux le problème c'est que
cette écluse on peut la voir pendant
trois jours trois jours donc si les
vétérinaires nous disent bon alors là en
fait on a besoin de plusieurs semaines
de traitement il est parasité je ne sais
quoi et ben nous au bout de trois jours
on est obligé d'ouvrir les cuisses
pourquoi parce que ça coûterait 200000
euros par jour de maintenir cette écluse
fermée
bon elle me dit aussi on a un problème
aussi de financement c'est à dire que la
barge et le camion qui va servir à
transporter c'est surtout la barge qui
coûtais cher à sortir le béluga de l'eau
et à l'amener et à l'amener sur le
camion qui va l'emmener à Ouistreham va
coûter 30000 euros l'État n'a pas 30000
euros à mettre dans ce sauvetage donc je
ne peux pas valider l'opération si je
n'ai pas les sous je dis ok très bien on
fait une levée de fond on poste une
cagnotte sur les réseaux sociaux si
j'étais en France en quatre heures on
lève les 30000 euros problème résolu
alors c'est là que
l'opération commence donc le soir on met
des filets encore une fois on n'est pas
prêt du tout en France ce genre
d'opération donc là c'est ce qui a été
possible de faire avec le Marineland
avec un fil à qui était loin d'être
idéal mais qui était le mieux qu'on ait
trouvé dans le temps imparti donc c'est
ça aussi que ça a mis en lumière c'est
que c'est indispensable qu'on est en
France le matériel à disposition tout de
suite donc on a des plongeurs à l'eau
avec le filet qui se referme
progressivement le niveau de l'écluse
qui descend
et là il y a 10 qui est dans le filet
voilà
donc c'est quelque chose qui est
stressant pour l'animal mais là on est
dans un cas de figure où c'est ça ou on
le laisse mourir dans l'écluse
donc là il est sur le camion il est sur
la barge juste avant de monter dans le
camion il y a beaucoup de choses à
redire là-dessus
beaucoup de temps perdu ça a été ça a
été très compliqué il y a beaucoup de
choses à apprendre de cette de cette
expérience on a eu plusieurs cas donc je
vous parlerai d'autres cas tout à
l'heure mais sur ce cas là moi j'ai fait
un rapport sur tous les cas qu'on a eu
et sur celui-là j'arrive pas encore à
faire le rapport parce que ça a été très
très difficile pour nous de vivre cette
expérience donc ça c'est lisse dans le
camion
avant que les vétérinaires décident de
l'euthanasier parce qu'il est en
détresse respiratoire
et donc et donc malheureusement il a
terminé il a terminé l'euthanasie
cette image là c'est pour illustrer un
peu la folie médiatique qui a eu autour
de ce Scala vraiment on n'a jamais fait
autant
d'interview les réseaux sociaux se sont
emballés on a eu des journalistes qui
venaient de Chine des États-Unis de
Russes de partout dans le monde pour un
béluga
nous forcément ça nous interpelle aussi
par rapport à cette indifférence à
laquelle on est confronté sur ce qu'on
fait par ailleurs pour des milliers
d'individus donc on voit bien que là il
y a une pression médiatique une pression
de l'opinion publique qui est très
importante qui a du bon cela dit parce
que ça pousse aussi d'une certaine façon
les autorités à mettre en place des
mesures et on se dit bah on va pas
laisser mourir les individus comme ça
sans rien tenter donc la pression
médiatique il a pression l'opinion
publique elle a du bon par contre il y a
aussi quand même une sorte de dissonance
cognitive dans le fait que il y a
beaucoup de gens qui se sont émus de ces
cas-là et qui se posent pas du tout du
tout la question de savoir quelle est
leur impact quotidien sur l'océan et sur
les populations dont sont représentants
ces individus on a eu aussi énormément
de critiques de personnes qui nous ont
critiqué pour tout elles sont contraires
c'est à dire pourquoi vous l'avez pas eu
thanatié tout de suite pourquoi vous
vous êtes acharné à essayer de le sortir
vous avez fait que prolonger ses
souffrances ou pourquoi vous allez
finalement décider de l'euthanasier donc
sur la question de l'euthanasie c'est
des décisions vétérinaires moi pour ma
part ce qui m'importe c'est surtout que
l'animal ne souffre pas inutilement et
par contre que s'il y a la moindre
chance de s'en sortir qu'on fasse tout
pour le faire et pour l'anecdote Robert
Michou à qui j'en ai reparlé par la
suite qui m'avait dit que l'euthanasie
était prématurée ma vie ensuite mon
vétérinaire lui pensait qu'il aurait
fallu l'euthanasier pour éviter
l'emballement médiatique
ce à quoi je lui ai répondu ça n'est pas
une raison valable de Tania animal à mon
sens il était tout à fait d'accord
ça m'amène à un autre cas qui illustre
aussi la façon dont on gère ce genre de
choses en France c'est le cas de Sénat
c'est une orque qui de moi auparavant
s'est retrouvé aussi dans la scène qui
est passé par le même endroit
c'est-à-dire les sueur du Havre va
falloir se poser des questions quand
même sur ce qui se passe au niveau de
cette estuaire cet orgue allait rester
pendant 15 jours dans la scène elle
s'est enfoncée jusqu'à 150 km dans les
terres sans que rien ne soit fait donc
nous quand on a compris que rien n'était
fait on a mobilisé un bateau on a pris
contact avec la préfecture et on s'est
mis à la chercher et le problème c'est
que ben on l'a trouvé mais elle était
malheureusement morte
donc on ne l'a même pas vu vivante en
tout cas moi personnellement je n'ai pas
vision je n'ai vu que morte
ça c'est l'état de sa peau après 15
jours dans la Seine voilà et là ce qu'il
aurait fallu faire une ce qu'on a dit
c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'on l'a laissé
s'enfoncer aussi loin dans les terres
elle a été spotée elle a été repérée
alors qu'elle était encore dans
l'estuaire à ce moment-là il aurait
fallu déjà la monitorer 24 heures sur 24
et mettre en place un mur de son avec
des bateaux pour l'empêcher de rentrer
aussi loin aussi loin dans les terres
l'eau douce chaude évidemment pas adapté
aux mammifères marins et donc voilà le
genre de choses que ça peut donner
un autre cas c'est un rorqual septembre
dernier c'est le troisième Orcal qui
s'échoue dans le Finistère Sud en 15
jours celui-ci est vivant
il est vivant moi je suis à une heure de
là quand je reçois un signalement avoir
qu'un vivant sur la plage de tiyanker
dans la baie de Douarnenez j'y vais je
fonce quand j'arrive sur place il y a
des gens de rne qui sont qui sont
présents qui ont mis un cordon de
sécurité donc j'y vais je me présente et
on me répond de garder mes distances
parce qu'ils sont en train de gérer une
tentative de renflouage bon tentative de
renflouage mais il y a pas de tunnel de
creuser il y a rien en fait ils lui
mettent des cordes et avec un bateau de
la SNSM il essaye de le tirer dans la
merde bon bah vous imaginez bien il
bouge pas d'un centimètre ça ne suffit
qu'à le cas le blesser et pourquoi vous
ne croisez pas de chenal assez trop
dangereux pour le personnel ok très bien
donc il loupe la marée montante la
première marée montante il était il
était sur la plage depuis à peu près 5
heures
à ce moment-là il est en plein soleil
ça c'est une photo du crépuscule donc
c'est
il est en plein soleil c'est drain là
c'est moi qui suis allé les chercher
chez les habitants du village d'à côté
parce que je dis à la personne du RL sur
place que il est en train de cramer au
soleil que la première chose à faire
déjà c'est de le protéger elle me dit
bah de toute façon il est mort il est
pas mort je le vois respirer il y a son
souffle elle me dit oui mais c'est une
question de temps avant qu'il meurt ok
très bien donc je suis évidemment
furieuse donc j'envoie un message de
ministre de la mère je vous dis ça c'est
pas possible en fait on est en train de
laisser mourir une baleine crever en
plein cagnard il y a pas les moyens de
l'euthanasier ça peut prendre des heures
voire des jours pour qu'elle meurt c'est
pas possible en 15 minutes j'ai
l'autorisation de passer je vais donc
cédrat sur sur la baleine
et
avec nos pelles on creuse un cheval
voilà au début on était au top 2 donc on
était pendant plusieurs heures deux
personnes à creuser un chenal en
attendant la marée montante qui arrivait
en fait à minuit à peu près on arrive à
obtenir l'autorisation d'avoir un
tractopelle qui va grandement de
facilité travail
tractopelle auquel justement la personne
du RNO était pas forcément d'accord il y
en a d'autres qui l'était mais pas tous
parce qu'en fait la crainte encore une
fois c'était qu'on remette cette baleine
à l'eau et qu'on perd le cadavre
et puis on nous disait là aussi bon
c'est une baleine qui est venue mourir
tranquillement vous êtes en train de
vous acharner laissez-la tranquille etc
donc ça c'est des gens qui savent pas
comment fonctionnent les balais non
parce que en fait une baleine qui est
sur la terre ferme subit la pesanteur et
elle s'écrase sous son propre poids elle
s'étouffe littéralement et ça peut
prendre encore une fois des heures voire
des jours donc une baleine qui meurt
doit mourir dans l'eau certainement pas
à terre et si même si elle était
condamnée s'il y avait le moindre acte
de charité qu'on puisse faire à son
égard si on peut pas l'euthanasier c'est
de la remettre à l'eau qu'elle me rend
en mer et alors ce qui est incroyable
c'est que donc ce chenal on l'a creusé à
minuit et demi la mariée et haute on
avait mis des cordes sous elles avec le
chenal donc qui permettait d'augmenter
le niveau d'eau et on s'attendait à ce
que ça prenne une demi-heure et qu'on
lutte pour la sortir et en fait quand
elle a senti la bonne vague en 5
secondes elle a déployé une force
absolument incroyable un geyser d’eau
qui nous a tous arrosé et elle est
partie en 5 secondes elle était en mer
c'était incroyable à vivre comme
événement malheureusement elle est morte
quand même parce que de toute façon les
13 heures supplémentaires qu'elle a
passé sur la plage lui ont été fatales
dernier cas c'est un phoque à Étretat
qui a été signalé en détresse et qui en
fait pour lequel on s'est mobilisé c'est
nous qui avons mis ce cordon de sécurité
le centre de soins qui était plus près
n'a pas voulu se déplacer parce qu'ils
ont jugé sur photos que c'était un vieil
individu en fin de vie qu'il fallait
laisser faire la nature un fox sa vie
entre 25 et 30 ans cette bague nous a
permis de savoir qu'en fait c'est un
faut qu'il y avait moins de 10 ans
voilà et qui malheureusement finalement
est mort est mort dans ce centre de
soins et là on a un cas similaire en
Angleterre où ils se sont déplacés même
si c'était un foc adulte et ils ont ils
ont euthanasié parce qu'il était il
était mourant mais au moins ils ont mis
un terme assez souffrances et ils n'ont
pas laissé agoniser un animal tout seul
sur la plage voilà je termine là dessus
j'ai beaucoup aimé dans la catégorie qui
a pu y avoir autour de ces sujets là
cette expression la citation de Gaël
Musquet ce que fait si shaper a du sens
car dans une époque aussi anxiogène voir
des adultes se mobiliser à ce point pour
sauver une baleine blanche redonne de
les efforts aux enfants et on a reçu
ce petit dessin qui nous a énormément
touché surtout que on n'a pas été
épargné dans cette affaire mais bon le
problème c'est pas nous mais c'est
surtout que je pense que si ces animaux
ne sont pas morts pour rien c'est si ça
éveille les consciences et si tous ceux
qui se sont émus pour eux pouvaient
s'interroger aussi sur leur rôle dans
l'océan
savoir que chaque individu vaut la peine
qu'on se batte pour lui puisque nous
sommes la plus grande force de
destruction du vivant
on le leur doit à chaque animal à chaque
enfant et à nous-mêmes parce que si
l'océan meurt nous n'aurons
biologiquement mais nous perdons aussi
notre âme merci à tous
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]